hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Brandi
price we're gonna watch the trailer
today for a movie called true story it's
completely fiction [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
door
true story stars James Franco and Jonah
Hill and is supposedly a drama really no
weird I know I already got a bunch of
[ __ ] douchebags we're gonna be like
Jim nails done serious rules and sues
James Franco I'm used to seeing them in
movies together where it's not serious
James Franco has become a part of that
comedy crowd like he's worked with Seth
Rogen plenty of times and he's made like
cameos and stuff and a lot of comedy so
yeah they were in this is the end
together playing themselves I'm a little
concerned that I'll have the ability to
fully wrap my head around what I'm
watching why just because it's a drama
III don't know
it might be one of those experiences
where I'm like they're doing really good
but I still can't get this thought out
of my head that what kind of dick jokes
were they making and me too me too
me Jonah Hill is great like he is a
fantastic dramatic actor and everyone
knows James Franco rocks it so I take
back everything I just said sorry
language and some disturbing journey
think after three years you can call me
Mike I'm actually going into the office
this article was about saving people's
lives you said write it up I said write
it out not make it up I did the best
with what I had you have a future ahead
of you Mike good master you know to be
honest I'm relieved it's over with the
times he turned into a real prick was
enough hello hi I'm a reporter with The
Oregonian I wanted to get your side on
the Christian Longo story who he
murdered his entire family why are you
telling me this because when they
apprehended him he said he was Mike
Finkel of the New York Times did he say
anything at all about why he claimed to
be me I hoped you might be able to tell
me that he was just a regular guy an
intelligent sane man he comes home one
night and feels this way I think it
makes no sense
thank you for seeing this so long guys
so I be
I'm followed your whole career I guess I
felt like Annie I want to tell you my
side of this only maybe at this point it
doesn't matter the truth always matters
I know it seems mad at you
this is a once-in-a-lifetime story don't
you see this is a second change
forbidden outcast that's not the man I
wanted to be come across system and he
wants to be
no Jill hey nice to meet you please
so Mike he's been a real friend to me I
just hope that we can be friends Tim I
believe we're doing what an
exceptionally dangerous man enjoys of so
many stories to tell and you chose his
actually he picked me didn't pick you
he used you we think he's already some
bigger game plan this isn't just about
me do you have to protect can't say you
think he's innocent to me my whole
reputations on the one don't give up on
me are you really gonna be the man who
might set him free
Chris did you do with your kids do ya
Felicity Jones is great sushi was in the
theory of everything she's a great
actress something tells me I'm going to
be able to accept the fact that they're
doing a drama really serious I think
this is one of the best times I've ever
seen Jonah Hill yeah I'm normal I know
and I hate to say this but I'm not a
huge fan of him it's interesting because
in Moneyball and in Wolf of Wall Street
it was still sort of like a comic relief
kind of role yeah and you still had that
comedic elements yeah exactly
no it was like straight this one it's
just a whole one like serious sincere
performance that's the most real I've
ever seen him yeah that's that's what
was making me buy it even yeah James
Franco was creepy as [ __ ] yeah like cuz
he does have that ability to be really
charming but then like do I trust this
guy you know I had this look in his eye
this crazy-looking as I like you might
kill you but anymore he does look like a
serial killer
yeah and the way that he moved his hands
I don't know if you noticed this but he
would always like kind of twitch so I
was like yes James Franco can be a
[ __ ] amazing character actor yeah one
of my most impressive performances I've
ever seen that a guy was spring breakers
actually you see that I didn't see it
yet like he is so good in that role I
got scarf ice on repeat I do really
respect and admire the fact that even
though if you hear Jonah Hill and James
Franco you're probably gonna think it's
a comedy I respect the fact that these
guys are like knowing that to see them
you want to laugh if you hear about the
mean together but to go like take the
chance and go you know what people will
be able to buy us like we can do this so
yeah it's cool to see them really
committed to these roles in this world
together like I think you'll be
interesting to be so comfortable doing
comedy with each other to see how that
you draw
together actually you know a lot of
times you I mean you prepare comedy and
drama the same way like that you prepare
everything the same way and then the
form is just a little bit different and
they already have an established
relationship with one and everything
with one another because they're friends
yeah exactly
the fact that like Jonah Hill and James
Franco have had to do a lot of improv
together just thing all these multiple
takes they've done together in movies
you know these guys are gonna be there's
gonna be no issue with them playing off
each other it's weird I had all these
initial concerns then I watch this and
then I realize I'm actually really
intrigued by this like yeah like there's
i watch a lot of I'm not gonna watch
like every [ __ ] movie that comes out
the movie looks good I know I'm probably
not gonna take the time to watch it but
I really think I'm gonna take time to
actually watch this movie it looks
really good yeah all right sweet that
looks awesome
yes good cinematography music seemed a
little dramatic thriller cliche ish to
me
to be honest I didn't bother me but I
could see where I would sort of did I
wonder how true this story actually is
because it's a based on a true story
yeah let's hope so
it better be I'll cut someone yeah that
good what's up with you I'm wanting to
hurt fat people yeah I mean gotta shanks
and fatties know if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and brandy has a channel to
does movie reviews a lot of indie flix
and Netflix check out her channel caught
up on shout outs so go to facebook.com
slash the real reject shout outs if you
say something that's interesting you
could earn yourself a shout out from
this [ __ ] and who better than to
say something about you than me and of
all the [ __ ] on YouTube I am by far
the best one yeah [ __ ] yeah I'm a great
fun
is a grave sake can I retract that semen
no it's a true story not between her and
I know that's Veronica no yeah but we're
waiting till marriage
if Veronica's mom's watching this sex
before marriage is a sin you'll go to
hell